diagonal l'actualité internationale du
jeu d'échecs émission spéciale tourna de
bienne tournoi extrêmement relevé
catégorie 17 qui a lieu en suisse
également quelques analyses du
championnat de paris nous analyserons
bien sûr une partie commenté ça sera la
partie kornoi gritching donc qui sont
les joueurs d'exception de ce plateau de
bienne tout de suite avant de parler du
tournoi je vais vous présenter notre
invité il a été trois fois champion de
france en 90 91 94 il est extrêmement
sympathique il un délicieux accent du
sud ouest il s'agit de marc santoro mon
triple champion de france de remettre
international bonjour marc m'a juré doit
donc tu es à paris en ce moment à
l'occasion du championnat de paris où tu
participes comment ça se passe je
participe effectivement je pilote et ça
se passe pas à pas facile et que sa
méthode est à dire tous les tournois
auxquels je fasse pour moi ce n'est pas
ce mal écrites ou un drama qui se passe
mais m donc il faut faire des tours de
grand maître plutôt que d open on
rappelle t-on à de grands maîtres c'est
sur invitation m'est on admettre les
tournois open s'est ouvert à tous tout
de suite nous allons vous commenter un
tournoi donc de grands maîtres sur
invitation avec six joueurs prestigieux
notamment donc c'est le tournoi de
vienne marque qui se déroule en suisse
avec la présence exceptionnelle de 8
hors corse noël 70 ans
super remarquable de combativité les
toujours aussi jeune c'est exceptionnel
excepté le voir comme un corps jeune
peut encore arriver à inventer à ce
patron est vrai que c'est difficile
d'avoir encore le punk est en revanche
je dois déjà c'est pas facile
donc on rappelle quand même marque
puisque chaque fois que tu viens il ya
une anomalie dans l'émission la dernière
fois donc vous pouvez revenir dans les
archives il ya eu un imminent cette fois
ci nous allons faire un petit système
nous allons mettre en place un système
quand tu ne sauras plus quoi dire eh
bien nous enverrons des sifflements
voilà
donc quand tu ne sais plus quoi dire
c'est sifflé immédiatement alors gris
tchouk
faut analyser gratuit qu'est-ce qu'il
faut dire aussi que c'était bien il a
dit ça quand on est jeune et joue à
vienne
mais moi je connais pas de résultats on
y trouve une bien belle foire aux
côtelettes bon déjà première chose à
faire quand on parle d'un tournoi que
vous ne connaissez a priori passer
d'autres présenter ce tournoi pour ça
nous avons été sur place à vienne nous
avons donc des images du sujet que nous
allons vous commentez on va d'abord
voulait diffuser donc le tournage
viennent avec les six grands maîtres
internationaux extrêmement fort tout de
suite
à
ça c'était donc la cérémonie d'ouverture
avec la petite musique et tous les
joueurs qui sont là donc nous voyons
yannick pelletier le joueur suisse
victoire corse noël 70 ans à sa gauche
donc alexei gritche look le phénomène
russe 17 ans seulement joël lautier la
star française numéro un français on
voit boris belfort ni si le joueur
israélien ex russe et peeters fille de
l'air est ici je vais le tient en pleine
action lors de la première ronde où il
jouait contre yannick pelletier jeu
lautier concentré ça fait un peu films
westerns italiens tout est dans le
regard je vais le pied extrêmement
concentré toujours alors que là il s'est
tourné
voilà donc toujours ce match
lautié painting dire que six joueurs
dans ce tournoi donc ici c'est alexander
guadeloupe très détendu c'est juste
avant le début de la partie et il est en
train de jouer contre eux fidelaire
voilà tout de suite c'est autre chose
dès que ces partis marque ne rigole plus
du tout et d'ailleurs dans cette partie
il s'est fait proprement pulvérisé par
un adversaire qui est donc le russe
peter spider qui est en face de lui que
nous allons voir
après le coup de grisou qu
on est choqué quand même très très
élégant il faut le noter donc voilà
pitard sud l'air qui n'est pas là pour
rigoler c'est un joueur extrêmement fort
de
1680 quelque chose et l'eau donc tout à
fait affûté et ici la jeunesse
dorée tout
d'abord que marc mossé du codir
et qui veut donc commenter un petit peu
ces images voilà marc platon joueurs de
prédilection à l'émotionnel suisse
c'est toujours c'est toujours très
propres et la suisse bien organisés ça
tourne bien les tournois ça commence à
l'heure tout est bien beau
8 heures chrono dont nous aurons une
interview tout à l'heure il n'est pas
facile d'interviewer il est assez âgée
mais toujours aussi teigneux victor
cutter le terrible avec une noyade très
sévère les jouer contre boris gelfand il
a créé l'exploit dès la première ronde
en le battant l'implant vu de loin peter
suite leurs comptes regrette yuke plan
de la salle puisqu'il ya également un
open assez relevé avec une vingtaine de
grands maîtres qui joue le tournoi open
qui est à côté du temps de remettre et
ici vous avez les célèbres écran de
démonstration où le public pouvait donc
suivre les parties voilà vous voyez la
position de la partie kornoi contre une
guerre froide ici c'était la partie
d'authier contre pelletier donc toutes
les positions sont là pour être suivis
par les spectateurs qui ont envie de les
voir voilà donc la fin de ce petit sujet
surviennent avec la pression finale de
juke qui abandonne contre aux fidèles
donc marque se tourne ensuite très
propres et très bien organisés et les
parties commencent à l'heure voilà
exactement c'est la suisse c'est la
suisse
bien nous allons donc commenter le
classement après trois rondes nous avons
donc en tête peter sud l'air la valeur
sûre épisode finder oui oui ils sont
tous très fort ce
que j'ai pu dire n'est pas dit que des
moutons sur le fritsch mai mais sinon
les autres beaters twitter oui ça fait
longtemps qu'il est déjà au top niveau
le nid sur trois donc ça c'est un très
beau score vente est déjà été plusieurs
fois championne l'urss
consécutivement plus de 8,2 fois
consécutive et une troisième fois plus
tard donc ça fait longtemps qu'il a déjà
percé bon mais c'est vrai qu'on avait
peut-être l'occasion de voir peut-être
au très haut niveau peut-être oui alors
tout à fait de justement il nous
détaillera les explications de cela dans
l'interview qui sera donc tout à leur
deuxième position nous avons victor
corse né avec deux points qui a donc
battu successivement boris gelfand et
ensuite il a battu un autre très fort
joueur c'était une grille tchouk la
partie que nous commencerons avant de
s'imposer très malheureusement contre
il n'y donc trop partie
effectivement il a deux cas sur trois a
une a perdu contre yannick pelletier
surprise les côtés qui est évidemment de
l'outsider de ce tournoi après avoir
battu les deux plus forts il perd contre
le plus fanatique dès lors je ne sais
pas je veux comme quand ça peut être
clasico avec qui il a besoin d'eux
d'avoir à l'adversaire qu'ils redoutent
tout cas pour pouvoir se donner à fond
parce que sinon j'ai l'impression qu'il
peut que se laisser aller peut-être à la
fantaisie
peut-être qu'il était un peu léger dans
cette partie contre une pelletée et à
son âge ça pardonne pas bah oui lui 300
à tous les achats parlons pas
mais c'est vrai que bon il a rien à
prouver contre contre jour combien ni
petit et quand elle n'était ni chanter
ni moins de trois fois
donc il peut se laisser un peu glissé
contre lille pelletier peut-être mais ça
peut être que yannick c'est d'ailleurs
très bien joué la partie ça ne bouge pas
3e 4e du tournoi boris golf hand et
annie pelletier donc justement yannick
pelletier 3 4e avec des seuils de 50% il
a un point de vue sur le droit à un joli
ça va mais il a battu corse n'avait fait
ni d'abate il a fait nul donc il a perdu
là il a fait nul à joël lautier la
première il a perdu contre boris gelfand
la deuxième il a battu campagne dans la
troisième manche 5e joël loti avec un
point donc je vais lautié
bon puisque c'est notre france et
nationale on va commenter un peu son
actualité en ce moment
joël lautier ne joue plus beaucoup et on
dépense énormément d'énergie pour
soutenir deux l'admirent kramnik donc je
ne sais pas marc si tu as été un jour
second dans ta vie mais en tout cas joel
gauthier ça a l'air de l'épuiser
complètement il arrivé à bienne
complètement épuisé après avoir préparé
vladimir kramnik canton à dortmund
peut-être que ça remet en question
d'être sous le nom d'un joueur quand
vladimir kramnik un convoi
tout ce qui peut voir ou à pas
on se dit des doutes ou peut être parce
que je pense qu'il a dû être profitable
mais peut-être qu'il faut une petite
période quelques mois peut-être six mois
pour que tout ça se remettre en place et
après je passe avec bénéfique
puisque la joie de lautier donc à
2675 il est bien classé dans ce tournoi
il n'a qu'1 point c'est donc pas très
bien il n'arrive pas à gagner deux
parties il a fait deux nuls
donc c'est plutôt une contre-performance
il aurait perdu gros géorgie
marque il faut il faut se renseigner
avant de venir donc il a perdu la
deuxième ronde face à l'as pieters
fidelaire dernier du tournoi et c'est là
la véritable surprise alexander get your
que tout le monde voit champion du monde
potentiel qui n'a que un demi point sur
trois après trois rondes c'est donc pas
bon du tout il a perdu contre speed
l'air et contre cornol avant de faire
nul contre galles font mais
c'est très très fort a lâché des autres
est très fort et peut-être qu'il manque
un peu d'expérience et encore ce
niveau-là mal de tournois qu'il a fait à
linares avait kasparov je crois ou
défini effectivement c'est bien calme
souvent des couples dernier s'est pas
créé de joueurs et c'est qu'on appelle
un fait c'était une première
confrontation à ce niveau là et c'est
quand même c'était donc un bon résultat
quand même et là mon métier qui manque
encore d'expérience autochtones niveau
c'est possible en tout cas donc
alexandre après tout un demi point c'est
la grosse déception nous allons tout de
suite passé aux interviews avec pour
commencer l'interview de l'organisateur
du responsable presse de ce ton advienne
il s'agit d'olivier brice h heure il va
nous présenter donc effectivement son
tournoi et toute la tradition qui va
avec donc tout de suite olivier brisse h
eures organisateurs deviennent
comporte un plateau tout à fait
remarquable puisqu'il ya donc entre
autres victor cornouaille alexei ketchup
quel est le secret pour inviter ses
joueurs prestigieux
le secret c'est d'abord la réputation de
bienne bienne est connue bienne a ses
qualités et ses défauts mais à bienne de
nombreux joueurs sont venus se faire
les dents ont réussi à obtenir des fois
des premiers succès ici on se rappelle
que joël lautier était venu à 14 ans ici
il avait déjà été invité pour jouer
l'open en 1987 par la suite il a joué
pour la société d'échecs de bienne il
s'est bien senti il est revenu maurice
galle fan lui a rencontré ici à trouver
si l'un des meilleurs ainsi plus grands
succès en 1993 remportant la terminale
donc on veut dire que la la tradition de
bienne nous aide à faire venir souvent
des des joueurs qui d'une part savent ce
qu'ils vont obtenir votre part ça leur
change aussi de ne pas toujours avoir
les mêmes joueurs
d'élite que l'on trouve dans les très
grands tournois de toute façon dit elle
n'aurait plus les moyens de régates et
dans les mêmes eaux que les dortmund
linares ou vie casée et on essaie
surtout aussi d'avoir des plateaux qui
sont chacun est différent avec une
variation de joueurs une partie
occidentale une partie en provenance de
l'ancienne urss au moins un voire deux
suisses ce qui n'est pas toujours
évident les gens qui parlent français
d'autres qui parlent allemand pour tenir
compte un petit peu de tout cela et des
générations différentes comme cette
année donc avec victor korshunov 70 ans
et alexandre dagry chaud qu'à 17 ans
quel est l'avenir du tournoi de vienne
l'avenir du tournoi de vienne il existe
ça c'est sûr l'année prochaine il y aura
la 35e édition qui va coïncider avec une
grande exposition nationale qui se
déroule dans quatre endroits en suisse
dont à bienne mais bienne continue à
exister cela ne fait quasiment aucun
doute par contre bienne a un peu les
mêmes problèmes les mêmes soucis que
tous les autres grands tournois en
europe ou même dans le monde sait que on
ne peut pas vraiment planifié sur le
long terme on doit vraiment attendre
qu'un festival que l'édition soit
terminé pour pouvoir planifier la
suivante en sachant sur quel soutien
financier on va pouvoir compter savoir
sur quels joueurs sur quel potentiel
humain pour nous aider donc c'est
vraiment du court terme à chaque fois
année après année olivier brisse hesher
merci merci à vous d'être venu voilà
donc l'organisateur du tournoi qui parle
français couramment puisque bien est une
ville bilingue on y parle aussi bien
français que allemand donc pour la
cérémonie d'ouverture et la cérémonie de
clôture s'est donc deux fois plus longue
puisque on fait les discours en deux
langues mais enfin c'est toujours un
plaisir d'y participer voilà donc ce
tournoi de vienne marque sans tourment
qui a été présenté par olivier brisse h
eures un plateau quand même assez
exceptionnel est plutôt bien fini si on
peut détailler le plateau dans son
intégralité oui c'est un bateau il ya
beaucoup de combativité il ya beaucoup
de joueurs combatifs en tout cas ce
tournoi tous les joueurs sont vraiment
sont déjà vus comme des choses à prouver
enfin quotidien encore des choses à
prouver même quand je tenais donc à city
se bat comme un lion surtout qu'au final
surtout quand j'ai
surtout copenhague qui a beaucoup de
choses à prouver le tournoi de vienne
donc effectivement est intéressant on va
rappeler comme le système puisqu'il à
six joueurs dix partis donc c'est un
système double ronde donc effectivement
les joueurs jouent ensemble il ya un
résultat et ensuite ils vont rejouer
ensemble
nokia peut-être un des matches dans le
match des matches dans le tournoi on a
peut-être envie de revenir pas envie de
torchlight contre yannick pelletier ya
aucun doute que dans la deuxième risque
d'être très énervé c'est sûr
un fait qui viennent d'arriver comme ça
depuis qu'il a quitté l'urss qui
s'étalait en suisse c'est le mélange en
suisse elle a six bateaux par un petit
jeu là quand même sort à ces restes de
le titiller qu'au port
moi ça me tirait
d'accord donc on rappelle qu'entre au
champion de paris était arrivée des
mésaventures similaires mais
malheureusement tu n'auras pas de match
revanche
c'est sûr
et on attendra open donc pas comme
maintenant on va fermer spécialement un
tournoi de double ronde donc nous allons
passer assez rapidement à la prochaine
interview qui va être en anglais il
s'agit d'une interview du russe valeur
sûre donc peter spider qui est donc
extrêmement fort depuis extrêmement
longtemps mais qu'on n'a pas vu à la
fiche depuis un certain bout de temps
marque effectivement il ne joue plus et
andré top niveau il va tout de suite
nous expliquer pourquoi en anglais et on
fera une traduction en français ça
paraît logique donc tout de suite plus
tard cela
pittsfield tournament so
good choc est
si longue
absence
it's you can dance to be played
by
gbi com
tous ses astra
nous sommes obligés de
hemmingford autobus les bonnes à
l'honneur
peter spuhler fuck you merci donc
peeters fidelaire
qu'est-ce qui nous a dit qu'il a reçus
de l'air et bien pourquoi il ne joue pas
si souvent et bien tout simplement parce
qu'ils essaient d'être sélectif dans les
tournois qui me choisit donc il ya une
sélection à faire leur marque je suppose
que tu as été confronté à ce problème
trop d'invitation des invitations de
mauvaise qualité de temps en temps il
faut savoir choisir ben oui bon c'est
bien de pouvoir choisir ça veut dire que
même choix déjà
bah oui mais oui je vous le ferai comme
moi c'est très bien mais je fais un peu
comme lui d'ailleurs m'a fait beau c'est
vrai que moi je vous donne pas trop la
peine de téléphoner à droite à gauche
qui sait que mon bon vieux téléphone
d'ailleurs soulagé on peut moins deux
fois mais bon toujours dit toujours de
soi je téléphone aux odeurs
yacco je veux donc effectivement le
tournoi de vienne a été choisi par peter
muller qui a été ravi d'accepter une
invitation pour deux raisons il aime
bien l'ambiance à bienne l'organisation
et sympathique le lieu est sympathique
et en même temps le tournoi est
extrêmement relevé dont catégorie 17
c'est quand même pas un petit tournoi du
dimanche en banlieue parisienne c'est un
énorme tournoi annuel c'est un monument
dans l'année donc il a été tout
simplement obligé d'accepter alors un
petit mot de suite lire sur gris tchouk
très important il a 17 ans seulement il
a le potentiel pour devenir champion du
monde marquez que tu partagent cette
opinion de peter sidler il faut selon
moi je passais beaucoup trop tôt pour
dire si le dernier gp du monde je crois
que spider lisais plus exactement qu'il
avait un potentiel déjà pour devenir un
très très fort joueur à faire partie du
gotha profond des nations prennent du
monde c'est encore une autre question
peut-être ne sachant qu'il n'a que 17
ans donc c'est quand même extrêmement
jeune
il a donc le potentiel effectivement il
va être vraisemblement dans les dix
meilleurs joueurs du monde très
prochainement mais en tout cas là il est
en train de manger son pain noir
puisqu'il a un demi sur trois après
trois rondes donc pas en pleine
possession de ses moyens avec son
dernier shoot mais nous allons y revenir
puisque la prochaine interview eh bien
ce sera celle d'alexander et juke qui
est jeune et ça se voit d'ailleurs
puisque ces réponses ne sont pas
toujours aussi percutante qu'on le
voudrait il n'est pas aussi
sensationnelle qu on apprend on pourrait
attendre de la part d'un jeune joueur
aussi talentueux pluie mais en tout cas
il est quand même efficace et il a des
idées assez claires donc marque avant de
voir l'interview peut-être tu peux nous
répéter ce que tu penses d'alexander
great choc
sur le vol de l'albatros
voilà on ne sait pas quoi dire donc il a
été sifflé immédiatement par un
sifflement de stéphane laborde qui
enregistre sa en studio bien entendu et
donc nous allons tout de suite voir
l'interview de tous que s'ils voulaient
se connaître l'avis de marc centre
romand sur ce jeune joueur talentueux je
vous invite à vous référer à la dernière
émission il est venu où il commentait le
tourne à dinard est donc mark canton
romand qui commente le temps d'amener
race et bien il ya un petit mot sur des
tubes tout à fait sympathique donc aller
voir ça dans les archives de diagonale
actu en attendant tout de suite nous
allons le voir 17 ans jeune élégant
l'atlas extrêmement fort alexander stubb
tout de suite 90 twist alexander we
choose your stuff romero hello
you are quite yoplait amine windev aussi
you when i was young lad silverwing can
you save your world en voiture passe tu
as au caire et les touilleurs the golden
bil in monaco
first great resort
5 étoiles une
compétition importante
you know
you well known as the changing your life
et deeside êtes
you will become bolt championne aux yeux
d'antoine to make any analysis and that
just what you want to see what happens
sauf qu'au hockey novice en matière de
winston à monteils suppose
mais
victor cornouaille
hockey mister good shoping ce lot
voilà alexander getxo qui nous détaille
sa carrière donc champion du monde non
champion de russie des moins de dix ans
il après jouer à cinq ans avec son père
grand maître à 16 ans il a gagné
les olympiades avec l'équipe russe il
était demi finaliste du championnat du
monde à calcutta en inde il vient de
devenir professionnel à la question
est-ce que vous pensez que vous allez
être champion du monde eh bien marquise
répond no comments
c'est normal qu'ils répondent du boss
parce que s'il dit ouais je vais devenir
championne il devient pas il a l'air
bête et puis s'il dit qu'il va pas le
devenir mais ce n'est pas quelque chose
et je savais quoi peut-être d'accord
donc ça te paraît logique de ne pas
commenter celui-ci les deux phrases donc
il vaut toujours gagné quand ils viivent
on attendra ça c'est pas bête
ça a l'air assez rationnel mais c'est
vrai que quand je ne tourne pas comme ça
aussi fort que ça dont un ferme et s'il
ne vient pas pour le gagner ça veut dire
que la prochaine fois n'est pas éviter
que je pense peut-être non c'est toi
s'il n'a pas tellement envie de voir un
joueur veut venir pour faire ainsi de
faire quelques au nul à un joueur pas
motivés ben oui enfin moody's pour pas
perdre et c'est tout pourrait peut-être
il pourrait gagner des parties mais si
les autres poussent trop fort on secoue
tous les joueurs poussent de leur côté
d'accord donc en fait c'est vrai que
c'est quand même plus spectaculaire de
tous qui êtes un joueur spectaculaire
puisque déjà il a déjà deux défaites
donc c'est quand même tout à son honneur
d'éviter les parties nulles pour ainsi
dire donc il a commenté également la
présence de victor cornouaille il est
enchanté de jouer victor cornouaille et
c'est là un des points forts de ce ton
advienne marque puisque il essaie de
regrouper des générations et donc faire
rencontrer des
et des joueurs alternative puisque c'est
quand même 70 ans contre 17 ans et c'est
un peu les jeux les jeux fernand nathan
c'est de 7 à 77 ans donc là c'est pareil
oui effectivement franchement même pas
après l'autre d'avoir versé 40 30 ans
peut-être le deuxième joueur du tournoi
et yannick pelletier qui a 24 ans c'est
le deuxième plus âgée jeune
équipier en tout cas il ya deux extrêmes
donc avec alexander est choquée victor
corse n'a alors victoire finale bon on a
déjà avant de voir l'interview qu'est ce
que tu en penses alors victoria bryce
est il qu'aujourd'hui j'ai l'occasion de
jouer plusieurs fois avec lui j'ai joué
quatre fois avec lui et j'ai perdu trois
parties j'ai réussi à la ligne partie
mais c'était un mineur k o eh ben c'est
un joueur et il sait bien parce qu'il
n'y a pas besoin de se préparer contre
lui parce que l'impression que tout ce
qui se passe et on arrive on entre on se
met sur l'échiquier on joue et puis tout
se passe là rien ne s'est passé à côté
j'ai la sensation à chaque fois cette
incitation aux troubles il n'ya pas ils
rentrent pas une ride réparation il a
pas de préparation qui ont indirectement
ils viennent là il boit il connaît plein
de choses mais il connaît pas ligne
directe quoi ils connaissent à ça il
fait son petit mélange sur l'échiquier
devant qui scella propos de 23
jours axés sur la préparation il
n'essaie pas de me laisser en tout cas
ne connaît pas donc on va dire de pièges
ou deux variantes gagnante précisément
mais il est juste en train de réviser en
permanence avec toute son expérience
voyez connu norman chose quand même et
je veux dire qu'il connaît pas de ligne
directe maintenant il ya beaucoup de
joueurs qui se préparent pour savoir sur
ça je fais ça sur ça je fais ça etc et
puis paf paf lui il ay la déposition il
a plusieurs positions mais alors après
il fait frais mais là je crois qu'il a
pas vraiment de c'est pour ça qu'il a
fléchi cas d'ingestion qui réfléchit un
petit peu dans l'ouverture quand même un
corner il réfléchit plus que un joueur
comme par exemple les français comme
david martial on est vraiment très
directif quoi donc victor conte
finalement alors plus généralement
j'attendais quand même une remarque un
peu différente ces circuits courts chose
c'est quand même une légende vivante 1 à
huy détruire aussi où il y ait ou
non mais bon ça tout le monde dressée
c'est ça c'est un fait toi c'est un fait
c'est peut-être un des rares joueurs qui
est effectivement il je crois que
c'était si dire qu'il disait non c'est
cris qui disait que c'est une des rares
joueurs qu'il n'a pas été champion du
monde quant à lui mérité de l'être
coquelles oui bah il a été deux fois
vice-champion du monde donc c'est tout à
fait remarquable et en face de lui il y
avait pas moins que anatoli karpov qui
domine est quand même complètement les
échecs en son temps donc tout de suite
nous allons voir l'interview de victor
cornouaille le suisse phénoménal donc
l'ancien russe ancien vice-champion du
monde 70 ans aujourd'hui toute sa
combativité
un joueur d'exception et images
wim
you come back
into
tout reste à boucler
living legends somme
inadéquation pièces
voient la victoire car je n'avais donc
extrêmement fatigué à ce moment là
puisqu'il venait de jouer pas moins de
six heures contre boris gelfand donc il
était épuisé il y avait de télévision
donc la télévision suisse romande et
canal web diagonale pour l'interviewer
ce n'était pas évident évident puisque
il était fatigué il arrêtait pas de
bouger et il était pas spécialement
coopératif pour faire cette interview
c'est à dire qu'est ce qui nous a dit
intéressant victor kornoi et bien que
on a l'impression qu'il est vraiment
désabusé qu'il est là
ce qu'il apprécie le plus c'est la
phrase qu'il a dit à la fin c'est qu'il
apprécie que le public l'apprécient
une réaction peut-être
tout le monde aime que les jeunes
nous aime quoi c'est normal dans ce
groupe il y en a qui jouent pour gagner
oui mais moi ce qui m'a inscrit mars qui
aura marqué c'est la question sur la
légende effectivement je pense que ce
qu'ils n'aiment pas c'est qu'on parle de
lui en tant que justement ce qu'il a
fait parce que ce qu'il veut c'est faire
c'est pas tellement avoir fait ce qu'il
a fait c'est du passé ce qui m'intéresse
c'est le présent que c'est un éternel
compétiteur à 70 ans c'est
impressionnant ça veut dire qu'il ya
encore il va encore faire des choses il
est motivé par la compétition et non pas
enfin il n'est pas resté sur c'est sur
ces bases sur donc sur son titre de
vice-champion du monde comme boris parce
qu'il a fait par exemple oui mais bien
ce que ça me dérange pas qu'on parle de
ça c'est ça les énerve
à la question vous est une légende
vivante qu'est ce que ça vous fait il
répond une autre question s'il vous
plaît ouais c'est donc il ne supporte
pas ça c'est victor corner c'est un
joueur actif et c'est maintenant c'est
enfin
le psychanalyste
allons donc suggéré une analyse en tout
cas voilà donc la dernière interview de
ce tournoi de vienne donc vous avez à
peu près tout vu maintenant marque c'est
moment de passer à l'action nous allons
commenter une partie cauchemar y joue
pour vous montrer que malgré ses
réponses un peu curieuse d'interviewer
un victor cochonneries il continue à
jouer elle a bien joué puisque il a
réussi à battre la jeune star montante
russe de 17 ans alors tout de suite
l'échiquier la position ces partis
victor corse neu avec les blancs qui
jouent des quatre des cinq sets une
partie assez long mais il a tout
simplement glisser les toucs c4 aussi ce
donc là sa part un petit peu comme un
dandy dame cavaliers f3c 6 le fameux
triangle
des bermudes
c'est une star ça c'est une semi slave
alors sur le coup qui avait laissé trois
ilets la vente notre boom a dépensé 4 où
les noirs ont tendance à égaliser assez
facilement
régulièrement donc on joue maintenant
principalement le coût de 2,3 pour
défendre l'option c4
ça a l'air bête comme ça mais il faut
quand même le faire
f5 et nous voilà donc marque dans le
stonewall le mur de pierre alors moi qui
joue l'un des sinon je supporte pas de
donner ma cause de 5 directement
effectivement je n'aime pas ces
positions n'avaient et c'est vrai que
bon c'est solide quoi c'est solide mais
chez lui j'aime bien être plus souple on
n'aime pas se faire des choses c'est
très
drôle cette tombola lors l'idée du
stonewall marx et d'empêcher évidemment
aux trois quarts vide alors la nettoyer
se préparait d'ailleurs des coteaux à
110 des thèmes ces deux premiers jours
c'est toujours un pêcheur 4 oui voilà
dix ans que l'on pêche mais vraiment
solide solidement puisque deux pions au
contrôle comme ça d'ailleurs donc
effectivement si les blancs ne peuvent
pas jouer au cas très bien on se demande
ce qu'ils peuvent faire dons qu'ils
peuvent évidemment manoeuvrer autour de
cette case aux cinq qui est le problème
majeur d'avoir avancé les deux pions f5
et des 5 mais il faut quand même trouver
un plan derrière et là on va voir ce
café cornouaille alors il commence par
se fout des trois donc ils sont les
pièces jusque là rien de très original
cavalli et si ce petit rock food et 6
maintenant le plan est bien cazaux 5 il
faut donc tenter d'échanger ses deux
fous pour prendre le contrôle des
caisses noires d'ailleurs peut-être 400
se justifie du pauvre de par le fait que
les banques jouent aux trois hommes
barbus pas sortir le fouet sur la
diagonale peut être mais c'est une des
subtilités ici on joue donc b3 la menace
directe et positionnelle c'est donc je
me fous à 3 qui va échanger les foucades
noir et il sera donc les noirs avec un
mauvais fond qui seraient sur la même
couleur que ses pions le fou donc c'est
vite ça c'est le mauvais fou donc si
vous voulez en savoir plus sur mauvais
faut vous pouvez aller dans diagonale la
leçon tactique et stratégie des bases et
là vous avez une leçon sur le move est
fou damas est donc pour éviter fou à
trois fouilles b2 on se dit il a
capitulé mais pas du tout puisque après
le prochain coup de grisou qui est donc
b6 on met le fou en baisse est
éventuellement jouer avec ses 5 qui jude
mc est maintenant
et hop il insiste il va rejouer x 3 pour
de nouveaux échanges et c'est fou fondé
cette fois trois très logique donc longs
de victor cochonneries qui a perdu du
temps mais c'est pas très grave
puisqu'il a réussi à accomplir ce qu'il
voulait c'est à dire les change de ces
fous qu'elle et b17
maintenant il prend en d5
donc évidemment ce que les noirs
voudrait c'est pouvoir reprendre du
point e pour ensuite jouer ces 5 mais là
c'est pas possible puisque le club est
inquiétant prise alors qu'il force c'est
prendre et 5,29 et fou prend des six
dames prend des six est tout simplement
qu'elle et ses 3 donc il ya eu échange
de pièces maintenant victor corse non il
ya un bon fous entre guillemets contre
un mauvais fou et effectivement la case
aux 5 peut être repassée sous contrôle
blouses là j'ai l'impression que les
blancs réussite aura ouverture il déduit
avoir moment après danseurs ou où les
noirs ont mal réagi parce
qu'effectivement ça aurait été bien de
prendre un but précis de faire cesser de
prendre avec une pièce mêlant dessins
quoi faire c'est simple s'il a réussi à
prendre un cavalier en d5 et le méchoui
karvelis et 3 le cavadee des 5 est donc
ici on peut dire qu'elle perçoit comme
une web statique mais thomas commin à
moi je pense qu'il est content d'arriver
cette position construit à 6
mb 2 alors encore faut-il maintenant
marc transformer davantage à ou ne sait
pas gagner quand même comme il se doit
d'être gagné c'est avec un quad et
fabrique des noirs en plus beaucoup de
contres jeu quand même venir du jour la
case de quatre fois mais je crois ce que
les attaques sur le roc sur le fond noir
ça difficile quoi des trucs un peu
cavalier ou quatre roues ça s'échange
vers toi aussi cinq six cavaliers le
cadre donc avec petit rock tour f 6
tours h6 une attaque optimiste qui peut
marcher effectivement mais mélanie mox
en ligne le 15 novembre effectivement ça
passe et athlétique est passé de pièces
non qu'ici on peut dire que victor
cochonneries et tranquille maintenant et
il faut qu'il trouve un plan d'attaqué
puisque quand même les noirs enfin il ne
suffit pas d'une case pour gagner
jusqu'à preuve du contraire
donc il joue b 4 mai 4 un coup
éventuellement trouver des 5 et 6 les
noirs jouent eux b5 et bien là c'est
très simple on pas mettre un camion c5
et et voilà il faut se méfier de la c4
parce qu'après le ch est axée sur ces
noms rassemblement sur des synthés
l'idée de jouer à 2 à 4 oui directement
pour attac estion
forcer les noirs à prendre nos preuves
montrant des cavaliers environnement et
là c'est un net avantage donc tour à ses
huit des douze à quatre deux corps plein
qui pousse ses pions on va voir quelle
est l'idée après eh bien je crois qu'en
fait on va vous expliquer tout de suite
c'est de museler ce fou mais c'est faux
puisque quand on a mis un point b 5 et
bien le foot 17 il ne peut plus vraiment
plus sortir ne peut pas jouer dès qu'un
seul ou avec la noire vous pouvez les
blogs avec les blancs bas à 5 le
problème que tu mentionné marc c'est que
biya b5 suis de remplacement du cavalier
un oui anne decis via des sites d'esprit
sera cassée 4 une fois qu'il en soit si
on prend on reprend du pillon des et le
fauve et ça devient très fort ce genre
de position c'est toujours délicat où il
ya les deux clubs c'est peut-être le
récompenser le premier qui arrive sur la
case faible qui
aimait s'y est beaucoup une hormone
pression de carbone c'est cet énorme
comme des c4 est très difficile aussi à
supporter cavaliers aux quatre catcheurs
qui cherchent des échanges de pièces
refusée par les choeurs cochonneries
évidemment cavalia 2 donc ici ce qu'il
faut voir la grosse différence entre 4,4
et la cado cinq marques c'est que la
case de 4 elle est instable le pion f
peut très bien aller sur l'a43 j'en ai
donc récupérer contrôle c'est
aussi ça dérape un lien plus en plus la
case 1 4i bluff l'acoss 2,5 et noir oui
donc ça ça joue avec la couleur des
fonds voilà ici est-ce qu'on peut
envisager un plan comme eux cinq
messes et des beatles avec déjà une
poêle faire de suite mais a pris 1,5 g
ce qui agace des 4 c'est indissociable
on échange simplement on fait un pion
isolé et toujours le fond c'est vrai le
faux sera toujours mais je crois que au
contraire leur positionnement qu'est ce
qu'il doit faire il ne veut pas bouger
et doit aussi d'échanger des tours
peut-être échanger les dames parce que
c'est un détour les dames je pense que
ça devrait pouvoir tenir pour les points
noirs quoi et bien voyons comment victor
gers a donc et surtout damas sept tours
fc 1 naturellement pour n'y a qu'une
seule colonne ouverte on peut dire que
les échanges sont proches dont les
personnes seront tolérés que l'autre et
la colonne mais ça s'est passé pas si
facile c'est pas si évident mais il se
trouve que les gars passe et où il ya
passé d' espace puisqu'elle a commencé
il ya pas assez d espace pour jouer pour
les blogs sur les colonnes a et b donc
effectivement il faut changer une tour
mais il conforte il ya plusieurs
colonnes peut éviter des changes et les
tours qu'on a un petit avantage si on
contrôle bien les cases de rentrer des
tours adverses donc en fait on veut
éviter les changes détour parce que ça
on ne rompt continua à ce que dire de
relations complexes voilà et nos tours
ont pu nous donner environ pour
améliorer un potentiel qui est supérieur
c'est difficile à gérer ce genre de
choses donc ici victor corner trouve pas
de solution pour pas les échanger mais
il se dit que même après l'échangé
évidemment il restera toujours un petit
peu cavalier des six ça c'est une bonne
case pour le cavalier puisque là on peut
on peut dire que la menace des noirs cb
5 eca et c4 donc c'est intolérable peter
corps change ou des 5 lui même à 5
donc sorti en trombe et 5 on aurait
peut-être pris du fou pour commencé à
pilonner un peu le cube et 6,6 nerfs
commencent à ouvrir les colonnes il ya
plus un plus même si le chrono sur
aprilia de gaza cet été la casa 4 c'est
à dire qu'il peut revenir à la carte
d'akébé s'ils se disent que la bce peut
être attaqué donc la réaction normale
c'est tout à fait logique mais on voit
que le foot 17 maintenant il est au plus
mal donc ça va contre ça continue damas
trois un petit clouage lecavalier et
chlorés peut-être une petite menace
cavaliers aux cinq au passage est ce
qu'on peut faire à tour sa course
poursuite s'est jouée tout reprend c'est
un temps pensé 1 et tours s'est vite
tout à fait donc là ça des clous en fait
puisque sortent en pente ou en rentrant
du cavalier et pas de problème
d'ailleurs c'est la partie tout reprend
cavaliers prendre et dames c3 donc voilà
donc nous arrivons dans cette position
là c'est un moment assez critique
puisqu'on vient d'échanger toutes les
tours la structure de pion à évoluer
maintenant cornouaille a réussi à fermer
de ce côté là le fou bessette est
toujours catastrophiquement placé mais
il faut trouver un moyen d'entrer donc
l'info qu'est-ce que tu suggères dans ce
genre de position les morts devaient
changer les nobles ainsi le singinois je
viens je passerai s'égalisent quoi oui
bon un mais quatre faut pas exagérer
parce que je pense quand viendra le cube
et 4 c l'idée immédiate pour les changes
des dames prennent alors un peu dur
d'hommes c7 le tenir si nécessaire quand
même qui est très fort en avec le fouet
cette année 17 et manas des limites
échec ça fait peur donc pour l'instant
on ne peut pas jouer d'amd 4 donc a
priori frais joué comme des six pour
essayer de recycler peut-être cavaliers
les cavaliers s'est vite c'est-à-dire le
cabinet 7 peut pas bouger parce qu'ils
voient comme un contrôle à cause de ça
donc le plan des noirs encore une fois
c'est d'attendre essayé d'échanger les
dames et et voir mais alors ce qui est
très intéressant c'est de connaître le
plan des blancs or le plan des blancs
c'est ne pas changer les nappes taies te
mettre un cavalier à 9 5 par ko diocèse
pour avoir la classe des 4 après c'est
possible si l'empreinte 6,16 donc ça
sera une transformation puisque après
laquelle vannes éperon reprend du pillon
et on essaie de s'installer en d4 c'est
un plan possible écorchant il ne l'a pas
choisie sur dame des six il a joué
cavalier quatre cavaliers 7 et h4 sert
qu'en fait il a commencé à créer des
affaiblissements vers le roi de région
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas de dépôt de
postes possibles puisque les noirs ont
du mal à trouver
chez les dames parce que il ya dans baby
dame s'est vite mais un corps aussi sain
de corps emprise vitesse limite ses
passions puisque c'est à présent donc
c'est plus lent et donc ils profitent
effectivement pour encore profitent des
dames quoi pour mettre un peu de
pression à noter que dans cette mission
marty tous les cavaliers a été changé ça
ferait un nul évidente ça serait nul
tout simple puisque le foot est roi est
incapable d'attaquer cette structure de
pions c'est surtout les cavaliers qui
s'immisce dans la structure de stonewall
cavaliers fuite donc là on recycle comme
on a
essayé de libérer soldats et pour voir
la roller 6 kg de la
9-5 évidemment c'est le problème et on
peut pas tout faire les kilomètres
califonie pouvait pas jouer cavalli j'ai
six à huit mètres l'autre à 9,8 pour
n'aura pu essayer qu'il est sans intérêt
de 6 qui défend la casaque et la dame
qui peuvent venir enseigner h5 de toute
façon dans cette motion maintenant plus
de 86 ça c'est sûr il veut empêcher les
choses des cavaliers fous ces beats ça
ça peut se comprendre on va recycler le
fou quand même on va le replacer en 17
et défendre aussi une fois qu'on
récupère le câble et fibre est peut être
passé par accepte il a plu beaucoup de
cascades pascal set ça fait ça fait
businesses qu'ochoa 6 s et ça devient
traduire la pression de la turquie comme
très resserrée territoire corse mais n'a
pas relâché la pression ça c'est assez
important cabello 5
fu 17
f3 donc là on sent que tout est sous
contrôle certes on voit deux cavaliers
museler un fou qui ne sort pas la dame
dont qui peut éventuellement tentés de
revenir mais bon c'est pas forcément non
plus évident puisque banon elle peut pas
puisque y accueille prend 17 km rossi ce
dont il ya deux cavaliers blanc super
fort et korstin qui est un plan qui est
maintenant de jouer g4 avec la taxe sur
cette diagonale
est-ce qu'il était impressionné ce que
positionne à la bhl et d'hommes c'est
parce que c'est une très facilement
premiers mois oui puisque le en fait la
pointe c'est que on attaque les blancs
l'attaqué donc pour pour attaquer il
faut les dalles alors que la dame a
réalisé d'un bluff et un contrôle a
cassé cette quoi ces référés de
particuliers mais là mon potentiel et
lent parce que la dame noire est
vraiment très dominés c'est une question
de potentiel ouais donc ici on va
regarder la suite de cette partie nous
reste que beaucoup de temps tu fous 1,8
g 4 tout de suite on attaque donc là ça
commence à créer des menaces quand même
puisque si on prend l'enlève cinq fois
open à ces dames ces deux peut-être un
petit coup d'attaqué le pion f5 g5 je
vais pas greccio que ça siffle
cavaliers eux deux ils fait rien 8h
porcherie mais maintenant la diagonale
est affaibli donc ça c'est ce qui va lui
permettre de gagner qui a été sept et on
peut remarquer qu' mais l'étau sur noirs
d'ethiopie faut mettre sur le problème
c'est que les dés soient pas de mode
jean est un petit peu naïf
oui puisque l'as cannes était là il peut
plus sortir du tout ouais c'est ça
facile peut sortir en passant par
l'afsset j'évitais en corse c'est
soit sortie face à 6 non il faut pas se
poser la question que faire du faux 8
laqué noir et pour ça la réponse et ça
c'est ce plan là comme des fous sur la
cachette où il sera sur une diagonale où
il pourra s'échanger mais même comme ça
c'est pas encore terminée moi j'ai deux
donc la marque comme tu l'as dit
plusieurs fois après qu'il prend ça on
reprend du pied et ensuite nous avons la
casse des quatre ça c'est sûr h 6
kg 3 donc on pilonne le pion bref vous
voir sur ces images on le force une
réaction jean pranger capture prend que
les quatre ici la domination est de plus
en plus gigantesque je crois qu'on peut
le dire maintenant ça va se passer sur
la bande de gaza est ce qu'il peut
arriver à faire quoi que sa
ceinture prendre cinq dames c5 il veut
toujours échanger les dames c'est clair
mais corchia il ne veut toujours pas
d'âme des deux dames c'est cette
dmp 2 donc là ça tournicote un petit peu
c'est bien il est vrai qu au niveau de
cette localité de vinaigre et pleinement
il peut les sur oculaires dont c'était
impressionnant et une fois qu'ils
lançaient vite que la casa c'est dans la
ville pays bas et si vous allez chez 8
aussi paul est nulle part où exactement
non cavani s est terminée vers un rôle
défensif pour toute la partie le fou en
revanche lui il peut revenir sur la case
h7 mais c'est long c'est pas facile et
une cartouche ne va malheureusement pas
y arriver toujours rage et sept
cavaliers deux corps jeune homme lui au
moins il sait quoi faire de ses pièces
puisque c'est beaucoup plus facile
d'ailleurs qu'ils vivent des quatre
rangées bits donc là on ne peut pas y
aller puis sculptures de 5 est en prise
enfin c'est dans le vent
roy f2 on replace la position des pièces
il n'est pas pressé avec les blancs
puisque comme on l'a dit il ya aucune
pièce noire qui peut revenir faut s est
donc ça y est c'est le petit tentative
d'amener 4 on vit ce projet cette dame
ces trois moments très importants
propose la finale oppose de finale donc
il faut regarder ce qui se passe sur
dame procéderont
qu'avait dépensé 3
et maintenant qu'est ce qui pourrait
bien se passer dans cette somme il faut
d'abord mettre k o dan nica trop loin
des 84 parce que sinon surcote pour y
avoir de décote qui s'investit avec
l'homme après les tests pré peut être pu
passer alors justement je pense que tout
simplement l'idée séduit 4 si jamais il
ya des caps on va revenir prendre
l'option avec lequel elle vient ensuite
avec le fonseca et attaqué le bureau sis
donc dans cette position ce qu'il faut
voir c'est que victor qu'en jeu mais il
ya sans doute calcul est assez
précisément il ya les menaces et aux
quatre qu'une fois que l'option sera en
tout cas tu aurais plus de viande est
simple puisque le roi va venir sur la
case des quatre également donc énorme
pression toutes les pièces centralisée
et la faiblesse sélections v6 l'autre
ses pions au cices il suffit de mettre
une fois de trop loin des 4 interdit de
ces quatre attaques b6 locaux
accueillent ces 8es foulées 7 voilà donc
en gros en gros les blancs peuvent
mettre les pièces sur des pressions
tellement forte que cette finale va être
gagnante on va commencer par les leurs
en d4 ensuite on joue à quatre on va
prendre du fou et mettre le québec dans
ses cadres comme tu l'as dit donc voilà
le roi ivala le fou il va là et le
cavalier ivala et ensuite ça devient
indéfendable mais tout de suite nous
allons revenir la partie de ces trois
dames dès 8 heures qu'a priori ça veut
dire que ça veut dire a privé arsenal a
perdu oui parce que sinon peuvent pas
des changes
aucun une chance de revenir même des
vies 3 2 victor qui prend son temps fou
j'ai vite ça y est il veut revenir mais
où ils menacent pas encore tout à fait
puisque tu avais si cette emprise enfin
- la food est un rouage fuite damas 3
toujours pas de menace particulière mais
les noirs n'ont toujours pas grand chose
à faire on veut peut-être joué dam des
six niveaux là bien sûr vous la voyez
comme un coup assez fort donc qu'elle va
laisser vite fort c'est
fou j'ai si on m'avait pas laissée
sortir le connaissent disent vis
cette
fougue et un design aux orages beat
dames c'est un bon petit coup un petit
coup la menace ont peut-être d'amasser 2
celui d'alger 6 ça peut être ça peut en
être une peut-être dams et 6 suivi d'un
massage donc en tout cas qu'à madiot
cette dame f1
attention là on menace d'annette 6 est
appliquée et s'est vite qu'elle et ses
six attaques la dame puis fera près de
dabo 9,6 voilà la dame variés et
passionnants l'accordina ou en fuite
avec le fourbe et un qui fait un très
beau travail sur toutes les cases
blanches le cas au lycée 6 contre la
casse de cinq hommes plus qu'avec la
séquence domine brice est vite
thiam et cazaux seul et après avoir fait
de même six des huit il ya peut-être
plus plu donc sur supposons par exemple
coup d'essai cette étude a même si ces
chutes un peu van damme et 6 échecs
dames j'ai cet homme des 8èmes g7 et dan
des mythes et lâcher parce qu'on peut
jouer bas il ya plus de coûts de plus de
coups on voit que la dame peut même pas
à tenter de venir sur la colonne f parce
que tout est contrôlé
le cavalier
ne peut plus bouger donc la défense et
même 17 cavaliers à cette même bessette
quasiment obligatoire même si bon temps
sur une pression peut jouer simplement
d'amener fuite à takashi ce gars de la
pression sur le terrain ça va gagner
assez rapidement donc après le coup de
canne et ses six matches où tu
abandonnes c'est tout à fait logique
donc une victoire technique de victor
corse louis qui quand même du début à la
fin ne s'est pas déconcentré 49 coup
précis et finalement on y joue que dans
les cordes ben c'est à dire qu'il est il
semblerait que ce soit parti great suki
mann heat et deux de profondeur de
pour pour arriver à trouver une défense
par rapport à une position parce que la
position qu'il au départ c'est vrai
qu'il a un peu moins bien quand les
fourmis noires s'échangent et que bon il
la commission ouverte les mots ça c'est
ça c'est pas c'est pas perdre il a pas
trouvé de ligne directrice il n'a pas
trouvé de planète en défense et de plan
sérieux sa part cité possible ou pas
parce qu'ils ont remonté des profondeurs
d'un dans les coulisses ans il
commandait le plan de défense alors ton
pronostic pour le tournage viennent
qu'elle favoriserait tchouk fi de leur
gueule fonde lautier cochonnailles quel
fan je pense qu'il faut toujours compter
sur lui
ce niveau là parce que call phones il
sera je pense forcément dessus de 50
pour ça oui et après ça dépend la partie
directe de nuit sur trois les autres ça
dépend je pense que j'ai fait c'est
peut-être le plus régulier connaissez le
mieux classé il à 2715 points et l'ont
donc c'est le seul à être plus de 2700
c'est le favori du tournoi et vainqueur
de la nasa essaie aussi de c'est le
joueur le plus solide aussi je pense
qu'il a il y pas complètement ces
tournois ont ils fait pas d il a alors
qu'il ya des joueurs comme richie est
activement aussi de larges parce qu'ils
sont il peut faire vraiment de temps
plus instable ah oui ils peuvent lui
peuvent fermer fermé des routes
extraordinaire et puis de l'autre côté
faire un résultat un petit peu ou très
en dessous de leur niveau quoi actualité
dans le reste du monde avec le champion
de paris donc que tu joues mark healy a
également donc il y as après cinq rondes
de jouer laurent frayssinet en tête du
tournoi 5 sur 5 pour notre plus grand
plaisir tout seul premier
oui mais il à 2600 mais il prouve qu'ils
aient les veaux m quelques même si la
phase i des partis c'est pas aussi
limpide que ça peut paraître sur
réception de papier il n'empêche qu'il
est toujours présent dans une partie et
il peut compenser quelquefois des manque
de connaissances peut-être pas par une
combativité et puis un talent tactique
une rapidité de calcul laurent
frayssinet quand même un très bon jour
une valeur assez sûr donc le championnat
et on vous le rappelle ça se déroule à
la halle carpentier porte de choisy 748
joueurs en lice au début du tournoi donc
répartis dans quatre tournois différents
laurent frayssinet en tête du tournoi 10
principales le premier parisien de ce
tournoi c'est luc bergeon
maître international qu'il ya quatre
années sur cinq qui réalise un très bon
tournoi on trouve une vingtaine de
grands maîtres dont moureilles inti of
phoenix est vite chez sap chez nikko
timochenko christian bauer qui est là
également et un autre grand maître
français enfin deux autres marques sans
tourment et jean-luc chavanon qui sont
venus sur paris faire un petit tournoi
amical donc maintenant ce tournoi quelle
chance gardes tu de remporter l'épreuve
de faire peut-être 4 sur 4
à 4 4 mais si je fais le dernier open
qui j'ai fait j'ai fini avec quatre sur
quatre mais j'ai aussi très mal commencé
donc si vous voulez venir voir marc
santoro mans en pleine action eh bien
vous venez à la halle carpentier les
parties se jouent à 19h en semaine vous
aurez avec l'occasion de voir un
champion en pleine action il y aura
également laurent frayssinet tanks
chabanon aller les voir de la part de
diagonale ils seront ravis de discuter
avec vous halle carpentier
porte de choisy que dire de plus mise à
part que ça termine dimanche remise des
prix dont dimanche à 18 heures pour ceux
que ça intéresse c'est la fin de cette
édition donc marquons va te remercier
d'être venu on va souhaiter une bonne
partie puisque tu joue ce soir
20h
une heure et demie la wii bon ça va de
mieux en mieux la chaleur est difficile
au poste porter cet ol beau merci de
nous avoir suivis c'est la pause pour
tout le mois d'août on vous donne rendez
vous en septembre à la rentrée merci